when did you get Silicon Valley so I was
on since season one so that was with
shooting season five now yes four or
five years ago but as a very small like
literally two line part right and then
they like me they brought me back for
like another episode and so I was on a
total of three episodes in the first
season
yeah but each episode I was on was
literally one scene in like two lines
that's how me in love yeah yeah Oh
killing Jacob she's great and she yeah I
love her yeah um yeah and then they get
the part got bigger and bigger
that's amazing you know it's TJ nice to
TJ's great to me
I love him we're very good friends he's
so awesome he told me I was his favorite
Asian friend TJ said that what's your
call no because well you I learned you
know we've been guests huh you just
learn yeah I'm absorbing so I've learned
so much I've absorbed so much yeah did
you see you know and I'll be honest you
want honest time I just made that song
oh that's not a segment no that's I just
makes nowadays right make it up all this
time I tell you how much feeling I feel
um scared
yeah I feel um happy that we have a
great guest I feel betrayed
I don't know why TJ problem yeah yeah
because the TJ um my eyes are vibrating
oh god I have no idea what that's all
about health and I'm having brain freeze
and I haven't eaten anything cold
sounds like an orgasm brain freeze
feeling a little regret yeah this kid is
amazing
so Jimmy I we're in the elevator what
did I ask you uh or do you ask me I
don't remember
hey what girls about girls am I getting
late
Yeah right like yeah I'm doing fine you
know but it's not like it's not like it
okay it's not like an avalanche of [ __ ]
yeah that's enough I having guests
never got in an avalanche in my whole
career interesting what's the most
Avalanche you've gotten avalanche
well this is my girlfriend you know that
I I figured out by now okay and you your
son you're talking as if I haven't heard
the worst of the worst things you don't
try to be polite now now's not the night
I pull I pulled a steeper and chris
d'elia in Florida once
what is that specifically like
back-to-back or multiple no this girl up
this girl I met at a show was a Tampa
Tampa right I've heard the story yeah
and she made love to me in my hotel room
live after-show you met her yeah and
when she left a preacher's daughter came
over right after that also another
audience member yeah and I know she was
a comic and I made love to her and in
one night and that's never happened
before after they were both white which
is a win that's a good double double
points yeah man that's good and um that
happened to me once Chris D'Elia that's
Chris D'Elia
Steve Byrne well this is when before
Steve Byrne was right married yeah
Steve's good-looking dude it was
half-asian dudes get laid you talk about
and I mean the half-asian girls are like
the hottest girls too so it's like
they're just beautiful yeah they all
look like Maggie Q or whatever right
yeah right here yeah there you go okay
have to defeat dark my holiday is ruined
you know what it's your curse you know
you're not a curse you're beautiful can
we like can you hold on one second your
energy right now is like [ __ ] up my
insides bro all right can we have some
like real clear train of thoughts here
and real lines of questioning okay okay
thank you
this is Dharma I got anxiety like like
[ __ ] every like five Oh
[Music]